facebook ceo mark zuckerberg is
responding to what can fairly be
described as scathing testimony from a
former facebook employee who called the
company morally bankrupt whistleblower
francis haugen told the senate panel
yesterday that facebook's own research
shows that it profits from stoking anger
and division also that instagram can be
harmful to teenagers in a facebook post
last night zuckerberg defended his
company writing at the heart of these
allegations
is this idea that we prioritize profit
over safety and well-being that's just
not true
joining us now is facebook's global head
of safety and tickety davis uh antigone
good morning to you thank you for being
here
consequential morning
mark zuckerberg says the company is
being
mischaracterized and let's go to the
heart of the allegation which is that
what's good for facebook is bad for teen
girls bad for democracy and bad for
america what does the company say to
that
well i i think fundamentally that the
characterization of the research and of
the work that we do was j was just off
i've worked at facebook for seven years
we have 40 000 people dedicated to these
issues we have we spent 13 billion
dollars in the last five years on these
issues we care deeply about it and
people do
are safe and secure on our on our
platform
antigone i think the question is about
the business model though and just to
put that 13 billion dollar investment in
context that's what you've spent on
safety and security that is a single
digit fraction of what the company has
taken in over that time period and you
spend a lot more on marketing and sales
so that's the core business concern
and and to that point when you guys talk
to investors and make financial filings
to the federal government like your 10k
report here you talk about engagement
being the top priority engagement and
user growth are you telling me now that
you're amending that that that's no
longer the priority
well let me touch on the business model
because i think that there's it's a very
short-sighted um description of our of
how we do business we put people first
we want people to have a positive
experience on our platform if we build a
platform that is filled with hate that
is not going to actually keep people
interested and it's not something people
are going to want to come to people come
to facebook to share with their photos
of their family and friends they come to
facebook to build their small business
if if it's filled with hate they're not
going to do that and our advertisers
aren't going to come back either
but antigone respectfully all the
available research publicly and what we
know about the research you guys have
internally is that engagement which is
the key business for facebook comes
primarily and most easily from
misinformation divisive content to give
you just one example nyu researchers
found that misinformation recently on
facebook gets six times the engagement
than accurate information so how can you
say that you don't profit off of some of
this harmful content
so the way our algorithm works in your
news feed is based on the things that
are of interest to you so what the
things that you engage with that said we
actually also have
within our systems things that actually
suppress things like click bait things
that are divisive so i think that just
fundamentally is a
um simplification of the way that our
the way that our news feed works
this is key here because when you talk
to investors and you file things with
the sec you say in fact one of the key
risks to your business is anything that
deprioritizes
engagement and user growth in the short
term
are you amending this now are you saying
that your algorithm is going to
prioritize good feelings first
not
engagement by any way
actually to give you to give you an
example of of the work that we've done
we made some adjustments to our
algorithm to create uh to get people
engaged in more meaningful social
interactions and we did that knowing
that it would reduce the amount of time
that people spent on our platform it did
in fact do that by 50 million hours a
day but in the long term that's a better
experience and that's actually better
for business
so just so people are crystal clear here
though what is better financially for
facebook if i spend an extra 30 minutes
of happy engagement or if i spend an
extra two hours in a bitter political
argument
i would say the first for sure
antigone um you speak of this algorithm
and i wanted to read what teen girls
told facebook in a survey and this is in
a disclosure halgen gave to congress
quote i keep looking at these images
after getting off instagram i don't know
sometimes i just don't eat or try to eat
less
i wish i had the money to get my nose or
other body parts fixed
when i keep looking at these pictures i
feel like i am too big
or not pretty enough
so what do you say to parents
like myself raising an 11 year old
daughter who has to wonder
is her spirit
her self-esteem being fractured every
single time she logs on
well i'm also a parent of raise a
teenage daughter and and have been a
teenage girl and actually have taught
middle school and teenage girls and
there is a is a
it is a hard place to be a teenager when
it comes to body image in in in this
world in particular
in the united states and we did this
research to try to understand where it
is that we may see that intersection of
a societal issue on our platform and
what can we do better
so for example we actually if someone
searches for eating disorder content on
our platform we actually uh pop up
resources to help them get support we
don't allow the promotion of that kind
of content on our on our on our platform
we work with a set of eating disorder
experts to help us figure out how to do
this best and what's really interesting
in that research which doesn't didn't
get talked about is that many teens
actually find in fact two out of the of
the
the
out of three um actually find that they
are able to uh
get more more help or bet or their
support through their engagement on on
instagram and what we want to do is
understand the difference between the
people who are who come to the platform
suffering and find it worse from those
who find it better and i'll give you an
example of a very specific thing that
teens actually uh shared with us so they
indicated that that when they see
content about somebody's journey to
recovery or uplifting content that
actually can be helpful to them so we're
presently working on something called
nudges where we would if we see someone
perhaps going down a a path that that is
negative a negative experience we
actually will nudge them towards that
uplifting content
you know antigone uh listen no one
watching francis uh hogan speak
would think that facebook would say god
i'm glad she's speaking up thank you so
much we appreciate what you're saying
here
but i do wonder if all of you at
facebook thought that she raised any
issues that made you think we need to
reconsider how we do some things francis
haugen was very credible she seemed
seemed very powerful seemed to know
exactly what she was talking about she
came uh she told 60 minutes and scott
pelly that she came with the kids called
receipts she made copies of over 10 000
pieces of of evidence because she said
she wanted to make sure that nobody
could refute or dispute what she was
saying so my question is did she raise
any issues that has you all thinking we
need to do things a little differently
around here
well i actually work on the teams that
care about these particular issues and
those are the teams that are actually
doing that research and looking at these
issues we care very much about people
having a positive experience people
feeling safe and and actually uh they're
well being being supported on our
platform so the issues that that that
she raised are actually issues that we
talk about internally to come up with
product changes so all this is done as
directional research to identify how we
can make sure that people are having a
positive experience and and she made it
clear though antigone that what you're
doing is not enough
what you're doing is not enough she even
made a point of saying look i don't
think mark zuckerberg is a bad guy i
don't think he won he intended to hurt
people but what you're doing is
absolutely according to her and the
research that and the evidence that she
presented is not enough
well what struck me actually about about
the hearing and about the presentation
is she showed
all these different documents and then
she never spoke to the product changes
and the product things that we've done
in relation to those documents and that
was actually what was incredibly
disheartening to me and to the thousands
of people who work on this at facebook
there's a different story to tell if you
look at the product changes so i'll give
another example of this there was
evidence given around suicide and
and suicide prevention and issues of
people who come to our platform who are
struggling with those issues facebook
has invested more than any other tech
company in this issue more than that
we've actually put together a a
reporting flow for people who
dedicated to this issue if you go to
report this content you can immediately
connect with someone who's a crisis
response provider
clearly we need more time for this i
know everybody wants regulation
including facebook we'll see and we want
to know what that regulation would be
it's not no one is saying that facebook
has malevolent malevolent actors inside
or is doing nothing it's the question is
is the business model itself
fundamentally a problem and does that
need to change
we hear you on the on the subject we
wait to hear more from congress and we'd
love to have you back and tiggity davis
thank you very much
thank you